500k
in 20 minutes of views is a good post
for me
up after that it's great lower than that
not that much
there's the video is doing great too
it's 30 million
already and uh
when someone says are you famous i'm
like i don't know
what do you do on social media i'm just
like i'm just myself you know
i hate when you grasp that
so who is leather pons i'm a single
child who was born in venezuela and i've
been making video content
since i was 16. so for the vine
selfie
okay who really knows who who someone is
i'm just too many things i can't say
i'm a singer because i i'm not only that
guys better i can't say i'm just a
youtuber because
i think i'm more instagrammer uh
content creator than that hi i'm miss
venezuela and you know since i was
little i love animals
so i think i say if someone's gonna
gonna ask me who i am i'm gonna be like
you know what i'm just
entertainer trying to make it
[Music]
are you venezuelan yeah are you
colombian yes
you come from a country that's different
it's good to have pride
and be proud of where you're coming from
so i think for my mom and my dad to keep
that hispanic
heritage alive it was definitely
important
because it's who i am i had a whole life
before social media
social media being an influencer wasn't
a thing i did not know you can become
famous
i knew i was big when i became the most
viewed person on vine
i reached a billion views after that
i moved to instagram
right there on instagram i continue
doing my little videos and then i move
to
youtube and then from youtube i move to
music
and then and now tick tock whenever
there's something new you just
transition
that's what i've been doing every year
[Music]
so it was i feel like it was easier
sometimes back then because it was so
authentic
it was like not something i planned it's
just it just happened
right in the middle of the road the
famous living room
is that hannah hey oh
hey
oh really hannah's one of my good
friends she i've known her for like four
years we've done so much
like content so i think she is someone
that in my career have grown up with
okay i got to memorize this everybody
quiet so the process
do you do content first the idea has to
come into your head
then you have to see who's going to be a
part of it who's the actor
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that
happened way too fast wait replay it
he only said three words but i see 23
here before toby
you know this is like in a foreign
language for me yeah you're going to
have to
and it's a lot of words then after that
you just film it no matter how many
hours it takes
yes
a lot of my fans are american and uh
also spanish it's an idea that has come
to me for a long time ago because
hannah's someone that sings these songs
but she doesn't sing them
that well
lily
when it comes to my mom obviously i
depend on her so much she's the best
mom ever when people ask me
who are you i'm like huh well i'm
definitely venezuela and my mom i can't
speak to my mom in
english so i'm forced to speak sp
spanish
the first video that went into like the
popular page was one
that was waking up my mom with a horn
i was in that moment where like all you
have to do is get to like
1 000 likes and you will get to the
popular page
like right now like that's not the
popular page even in tick tock you have
to get like
millions and millions it's insane
i have 40 million something followers
people that have been following me for
many years
but now you know what's the next step
what are the next 40 million followers
about
you